INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're
going to be talking about a bit
of continuing on our
discussion about building out
a web application.
Now to clarify again this
video and even to some extent,
pieces of the last video are not
necessarily one of those topics
where this is broadly applicable
across all aspects of cloud
computing, so much
as they're giving us
some tools to
enable us to explore
an aspect of cloud computing.
So, again, the big
picture here is
we want to understand how does
web development and specifically
web deployment
work in the cloud.
How do we really
leverage these resources
to the cloud to do this
task of web deployment?
We're doing that via building
out our own web application.
And specifically, we've chosen
to use the Flask framework
because it's a simple
enough one to use.
It's all Python-based and so
it allows us to stand languages
that we're comfortable with.
But I do want to be
clear here that this
is a piece of a much,
much bigger puzzle.
So you could use a better
statement that piece
that we're doing as far
as the actual deployment,
you could use any language
you wanted to for that.
We're again sticking to
Flask to keep it simple,
but I just wanted to provide
that clarification in case
there's any bit of confusion.
But either way, we're
basically picking up
from exactly where we left off.
Up to this point, we have
built a very, very simple Flask
application.
All it does is say Hello,
World on our page right here.
It is hosted via
an EC2 instance.
So you can see my EC2
instance here running.
Remember, I also added in
my security groups here.
I have an inbound
rule for port 5000
to allow traffic from anywhere.
So both of these.
So double-check that you
have those two things done.
Let me refresh it.
You should see it here
on this page as well.
Let me go back to security.
So yeah, you should see at
least this one right here.
We won't get into the
details of IPv4 versus 6,
but either way, you
should see that rule here
on your security group page
for your EC2 instance that's
running.
And then up to this
point, all I've
done, if I close out of
this here for a second,
clear this out so it's
a little easier to see.
Oh, I guess you don't
need this one here,
so we'll minimize that one.
And zoom in a bit.
I am in this folder here or
this directory that has--
so if we do ls, all it
has is an app in there
as well as my virtual
environment that I created.
So if you want to go
back through those steps,
again, in the previous video,
we have all the details
on exactly how to do that piece.
This is just saying
let's pick up from there.
We have a Flask
application live,
app.py is what it's called.
I'm in my virtual environment.
This again is not super
critical in how we're currently
working on this since we just
have one thing on this machine.
But down the line,
we'll want to be
able to either run
multiple projects
or at least be able
to extract what
libraries we're doing there.
So irrelevant right now.
Just recognize right now that
I have an app.py file in here.
If we look into
this app.py file,
all it says is from
flask import Flask app
= Flask name @app.route.
This right here,
the forward slash.
And then we're defining this
function called hello_world.
All it does is return this
HTML string of Hello, World!
wrapped in this tag of a header.
So that's the really
short explanation
of what we've done so far.
This is great.
This gives us a lot of
capacity right here.
But I will say it
also leaves something
to be desired in the sense
that our website doesn't really
do much.
It's very bare bones.
And also nothing at this
point is highlighted
why we need to be using Python
to do this as opposed to just
writing a single HTML file that
we host in many other ways.
So to that end, we're going to
actually in this video-- again,
it'll be hopefully a little bit
shorter than the previous ones,
but we're just going
to focus on how can we
expand this and actually
use the thing that
makes this valuable
of being in Python.
So first, I'm going
back out of this app.
So just Control-X,
back out of this app,
and then we're going to
leverage something that's
called templates.
So templates do a
really nice thing
of abstracting away all of our
front-end design, the HTML side
of this.
It abstracts that
away into its own file
so that we can write
really long complex files
and not have to worry about
something like this, where
we say, OK, well cram
all of the HTML website
into this little page right
here into this little string.
So we want to move this
out into its own file
and then also start to pull in
some actual Python functions.
So first order of
business is we are going
to make directory templates.
So you'll see that
within our folder
it just creates a
directory called templates.
And then we'll cd to templates.
Hit Enter.
And then from here, we're
going to create a index page.
So index being our home
page in this sense.
The same way we had
an index.html page
when we hosted via Apache.
So I'll do touch index.html.
And again, that'll just create
a blank HTML file in here.
Now, importantly, we
want to actually put
something in this file.
So let's open it up.
And in here, we're just
going to for now, put
a placeholder of what we had
before of h1 Hello, World!
We'll clarify.
This is coming from
the index.html file.
So a really long header.
But either way, this is going
to create our file here.
And so Control-X to save it.
Yes, Enter.
We're saving it.
And so now we've got
that file in there.
So we've got our templates
folder and this templates folder
would hold all of our front-end
code, all of our front-end HTML.
And then one
directory up, so cd..
Remember that takes
us one directory up
in our personal
website directory.
We have our app.py
file and our templates.
And again, if yours
doesn't show this,
that's because you haven't
created a virtual environment.
You can do that.
We show that again in the
past video, somewhere up here.
I have the code to
do that, right here.
So I said python3 -m venv myenv.
Again, not critical for this,
but just in case you're curious.
And then obviously
activate it, too.
In the pycache, this
gets auto-created
as we're executing Python files
to cache some information.
Again, irrelevant for right now.
So either way, that's
our templates file or one
of our HTML files in
our templates folder.
Now if we pop over
into our app.py file,
we can make some adjustments.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to say not only
from flask import Flask,
we're also going to say from
flask import render_template.
And render_template,
what it does
is it's a function that
does exactly what it says,
it is going to render
anything that is coming out
of our templates folder.
It'll auto-identify that, hey,
there is a special templates
folder, I'm going to use that
for any of my HTML files.
And I'm going to pull that
in when it's requested
to render that template.
And then if we come down
here now, we can change this.
And so instead of
returning the string,
we're going to return
render_template("index.html").
And so what that should do is
when we come to our web page
at the home page or we
have the main page here
at the root level, it is going
to run this function, which
right now all this
function does is return
the render_template index.html.
So when we launch
this page, fingers
crossed, what it should do
is show up our index page
that says Hello, World!
This is coming from
the index.html file.
So let's save this
and check that.
So remember to launch a
site or launch our app.
I'll get it up here.
I'm too lazy to type.
To launch our app, we're
going to first run export
FLASK_APP=app.py, basically
creating an environment variable
that says, whenever we're
launching a flask app,
we specifically mean
to run our app.py.
It just saves us having to
type a bunch of extra stuff
every time.
And then we'll do flask run and
--host=0.0.0.0 So if the app
didn't throw it or if the code
didn't throw an immediate error,
then we should be able to visit
this now at our IP address.
So I've already got one up,
so I'll create a new one.
So I copied the IP
address, paste this here,
and then :5000, and boom.
Hello, World!
This is coming from
the index.html file.
So that's good.
So now we have two
separate files.
This is starting
to get too complex.
Software development
here, right?
We have one file that
is our application code.
It's all Python.
And then we have one file
that is our HTML code
and that's all just again HTML.
Meaning that we could pass
this off to our designer
and say, hey, you
run wild on the HTML,
setting up the looks and
everything like that,
I'm going to focus solely
on the Python file.
This also makes web
development a lot cleaner too,
because now the web development
is going to be handled by--
or a better statement,
the web design
is going to be handled
by single files.
And so we can share
templates such
that if there is a
specific look that we're
going for a specific
theme of our website,
it's not me creating 10 HTML
files all with different logic
in them.
They can share
information across them.
And I can use the same
template, for example,
for different
functions depending
on what operations I'm doing.
So that's one piece of this.
The other thing I want
to show is that we
can make multiple websites.
So I'll try to find my
terminal again here.
So I'm just going to do
Control-C. And notice again,
Control-C to quit.
So Control-C, and that
pulls it back out of here.
And I'll run clear
just to clear out.
All that does is, again,
clear out the page
here so that you don't
see this long history.
It's a little easier to see.
I run that a lot.
Bam!
So now we have one page
for our-- let's say
that's our home
page, but maybe I
want to create an About Me page.
So what I'll do is I'll
actually cd back over
to our templates folder.
And I'll run nano, but
now I'm going to do it
on an about_me.html.
So an entirely new HTML page.
And this is where I'll
say, OK, header again
at the top of the page.
Here's my story!
And you could go on to put all
sorts of other information.
You could put paragraphs
in there now that say,
Born in 1992, Sharad,
and use ChatGPT
to autocomplete that story.
So anyway, that's how we
can create an About Me page,
so let's save and exit on that.
And then we'll pop back over to
our app page or our app itself.
So back up a level and
then open up our app.
And in here now,
spoiler alert, we're
going to use the @app.route.
But this time, we
can change what--
sorry, what page name we
want to put on for this.
So I'll say, for example,
that I want to do /about.
This is going to mean that
our website will look whatever
the IP address is,
but then /about.
And it'll take me
to the page that
contains my About Me page,
or a better statement,
it'll run whatever
function I type in here.
So I'm going to call
this function about_me.
And just like our last one, it's
going to return just a render
template right there like that.
So return about_me.html,
and typing.
It's not my strong suit.
About_me.html.
Now I'll save that.
Yes, Yes.
So we edited our app file,
we created our About Me page,
and now I'm just
tapping up to go back
to previous runs or previous
commands I've entered.
And I'm just going to go back
up to flask run and hit Enter.
And then I'll pop back
over to my app here.
Let's confirm again if I
rerun that I'm still back
to my home page.
But now I should just
be able to do /about.
And I hit an internal
server error.
Let's see what we
actually got as far
as internal server error goes.
There we go.
So you can see I pop
back over to my terminal
and I got this
long, scary error.
Rather than being scared,
notice that all I did
was make a typo
that said return.
Or you can see that down at
the bottom a little easier.
TemplateNotFound about_men.html.
OK.
Well, what is
about_men.html mean?
Well, if I can scroll back
again through the error code,
then eventually I'll see
that somewhere in here, yeah,
right up here, I said return
render_template about_men.html.
You probably didn't
make that silly typo,
so yours didn't show that.
But I'll go back in here.
And this is the part where it's
much easier to teach in person.
So somebody can laugh at me
first and then correct me
on that very obvious typo.
So save, exit.
Now we'll rerun the app.
Then I'll come back over here.
And heroically, yes.
[LAUGHS] Perfect.
So just zooming in here.
So you can see now.
Here's my story!
Born in 1992, Sharad.....
And I can just as simply
go back to the home page
and show what was there.
So you can see here
from a single IP
address and effectively a single
URL, we've now created two pages
and we can easily
bounce between those.
So there's nothing that says I
can't make a link between those
as well, too, so
might as well do that.
So let me go back
to my file here.
Control-C. We'll clear this out.
And I'll cd over to
my templates folder.
I'm going to start speeding
up now since I'm assuming
you're starting to pick it up.
You can always also
always pause, too.
Then I'll run nano.
And I'm going to do this
on our index.html page.
And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say,
hey, well, let's
just add a link here.
Add a link here so that you
can go to My About page without
having to actually type in
the URL bar up there /about.
So we've already got that here.
So we'll add a link which is
done via a href= and this is
again just HTML code.
I don't expect you to know HTML.
I don't expect you to do HTML.
I don't personally
love doing HTML,
so this is just to show
us a form of doing this.
And so all we're
doing here again
is creating a link
to our About Me page.
So this is the way you write
that in HTML if you're curious.
But again, not part of
this lesson by any means.
But in case you
need to see or later
on, if I ask you to put
a link in your page here,
this is the one line
of code to do that.
You would just specify whatever
the route is to your page.
So in this case, I said about.
But let's say you had a Contact
Me page and you did /contact
for that.
Well, you would just
do /contact there.
Oops, not Control-C,
Control-X. Yes, Enter.
And same thing, We'll
now rerun our app again.
And back to our app page and
we'll refresh our home page
and boom, right away our
About Me link is up here.
Click that and it'll
take you back to there.
And you could similarly put
a link back to the home page
from here that links
you back and forth.
And so you can start to see
now this is how you can really
quickly and easily build out--
honestly, a pretty
decent website.
Again, nothing stopping
us from bringing somebody
on who knows a bunch of HTML and
can make a really cool design
or using ChatGPT to help us
generate a bunch of HTML code,
at least as a starting point.
The important thing is right
now we're viewing ourselves
as the infrastructure team.
We're the ones setting up
all the backend so that way
we can easily plug
and play code.
But even more importantly,
we've deployed it as well, too.
We've deployed this to
a public-facing website.
I mean, if you open up an
incognito window so you're not
logged into anything--
I'll just do that really quick.
New incognito
window, paste, Enter.
And I can still hit this page.
So it's nothing special
about being logged in.
This is truly a publicly
available website.
If I don't terminate
this at the end of this,
this website will
stay live as long
as I'm paying the bill to AWS.
So that's an important
thing to remember is like,
again, I don't care
about the code.
It's why I'm not picky on.
You're writing your code, you
can copy and paste for me.
Or if you ever run
into issue, you're
like, I just need this
code to work so I can show
the rest of it, let me know.
I'm not going to
be grading on that.
So cool.
One last thing I
want to show then
is how do we actually
leverage Python
because we've done
some cool things.
Now we've linked between pages.
But if we look at our app again,
outside of the wrapper code,
the really only thing we're
doing is rendering a template.
We're just rendering some HTML.
So now how do we
unlock this capability
to use any and all the
Python logic we know so far?
Well, importantly,
first off, as long
as I'm not doing
up that route, I
can write any number of
functions into my code here.
So, for example, it'll
be common practice
to put this code
up here at the top,
so it's not interfering
with the flow of this.
But I'll do a new function
that I'll call todays_date.
And what this function should do
is return the date as a string.
So this is all just Python code.
Again, there's no
@app.route beginning this
because this is going
to be used later on.
So today = date.today.
Also, this is the annoying
part of writing code here
in nano is that I don't have all
the nice autocomplete features
and tabbing in, so I'm using
spaces as opposed to tabs.
That's a whole debate
for another day.
I prefer to use tabs, but
just make sure that you
keep everything in line.
So right here where
the t is in line
with this t line with this s.
That's important in
the context of Python.
And again, not really important
what this code is doing.
Just know that basically
what this is going to do
is it's going to return the
date in a very specific form.
I believe it is in the
form of month, day, year.
That's what that percent
sign b, percent sign d,
percent sign y represent.
They're special codes.
I think capital B is the
month written out in words.
Capital Y is the
year in four digits.
And then the lowercase
d should just
be the date or the
day of the month.
But don't quote me on that.
It was a while back when I
wrote these notes to myself.
And then we'll do return
"Today's date is" oop,
I'm doing the lazy form of
strings here, plus string date.
So what we're saying is, OK,
today's date = date.today.
And I actually need to
import the date function.
So let's do that first
before we get an error there.
From datetime import date.
And then that will return
a special date object.
And from that date object,
we'll extract the time.
You guys were probably
screaming at the screen
to put a parentheses there.
And then I created this string
date object from today's date,
just today.
And then I'm returning
a string that
just says today's date is,
and then whatever the date is.
Then I want to put
the date on my home
page, my index.html page.
So what I'll do is in
this hello_world function,
I'll call this my
today's date function.
So I'll say today
= today's_date().
And so that will run.
It'll create an
instance of my function.
So it'll return the
string of today's date
into this today object.
And then if I go down here,
I can pass special objects
to my template.
So I'll say the date=today,
which again is this object we
created right here in this line.
And now I'll go
Control-X. Yes, Enter.
Now I'll go over to my
templates, cd templates.
And I'll edit my
index.html page to say, OK,
well just below
my header, I want
to say h3, so a
third level header.
And then I do curly braces,
curly braces, the date,
curly braces, curly
braces, and h3.
And now we'll save that.
And we'll go run our app.
Oops, Could not import app.
That's because I'm in
the wrong directory.
I'm in the templates folder.
So back up one level.
Now we should be able to run it.
Then I'll pop over
here, hit Enter.
And you can see there, Today's
date is September 23, 2024.
So you can see what I'm
recording this video right here,
September 23, 2024.
So yours should
show whatever date
you're watching this video at.
We can still click our About
Me to come to our About page.
But again, the
real power of what
this is and I hope this isn't
lost on you because this was
an eye-opening moment
for me is again,
we go in here to
just nano app.py.
This is just Python code.
So truly anything and
everything you can ever
think of writing
Python code around,
you can do, and more
importantly, push to a website.
If you want to show off all the
cool analysis you did in a data
class and you want
a Data 3300 and you
want to push that to a website,
you can build the whole website
here.
And not only build the website,
you can make it interactive.
You can start to build
interactive features into this.
You can have sliders,
visualizations.
You can make all sorts
of complex frontends.
So all sorts of fancy HTML
pages, and many other frameworks
as well, too.
The sky's the limit with Flask.
If you just Google Flask and
anything else you can think of,
you're probably going
to find something.
If not Flask, Django or one
of the other Python frameworks
will have it as well.
And the cool thing again is
they all use the same approach
to deployment because
the deployment is
agnostic to the framework.
All we did was say we're
pushing this live in a local IP
address on our machine
here that our EC2 instance
and our EC2 instance is
just publicly available.
So a lot, a lot
of power in that.
Once you have that live,
you can share that link
with anybody and everybody.
You can show off to
future employers and say,
not only can I do the
analysis, but here's
the whole website where I
hosted it and managed this.
So, again, really,
really powerful.
And nothing today again
is unique or is even
about the Flask aspect of this.
It's just to show us that all
the tools and technologies
we're learning, they're
linked together.
That's what makes a
modern technology business
and that's what we're starting
to get the tool kit of.
That's what we're starting
to get the pieces of.
So take this, play around with
this, break this, restart it.
Worst case, if all this failed
and you keep getting errors,
delete your EC2 instance.
Restart it.
You'll probably find that there
is some little thing you made
a mistake on in the process.
That's OK.
So next time, we're
going to start
to move forward on developing
more complex websites.
Maybe not even
necessarily next time,
But throughout the
rest of this module.
We're going to start
to talk about creating
more complex websites.
We're going to talk
about version control.
So how can we manage this
because right now there's
a lot of code we're writing?
So we'll talk about Git, and all
sorts of other really important
details of this.
So either way, I
hope this was fun,
and I hope you had a
good time with this.
Let me know if you
run into issues
or you have any questions,
but otherwise, I'll
talk with you next time.
Bye.